madame monsieur bonsoir c'est la
catastrophe naturelle la plus meurtrière
en france depuis plus de dix ans
la majeure partie de ce journal sera
consacré la tempête qui a frappé le pays
ce week end et à ses conséquences
le bilan est terrible et il s'est encore
alourdi dans la journée une cinquantaine
de morts essentiellement sur la côte
atlantique en vendée et en charente
maritime comme vous le voyez sur ces
images aériennes de nombreuses communes
sont toujours inondées aujourd'hui nous
essayons de comprendre ce qui s'est
passé avec nos envoyés spéciaux et nos
invités
des maisons ont été construites en
dessous du niveau de la mer ce qui
provoque ce soir bien des interrogations
direction d'abord là